what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
another episode of pearl daily where I
cover this week's treachery debauchery
and craziness today I have a special
guest on the channel welcome Christine
hello again um you guys can go follow
her she is our newest Talent at the
network yes the link to her channel is
in the description so today you got some
craziness Christine okay I'm ready for
it so um we're going to watch a video
compilation of women just being awesome
and amazing let's go great what's
something that you never told her I your
ex-boyfriend are you
serious what the like this was supposed
to be like a fun little interview like
no this is for real but why you do that
on an interview though no I don't want
to do this anymore are you
serious these girls do not have any
brain our loyalty what is your craziest
College confessional I my ex-boyfriend's
best friend just for fun just for fun oh
all of his friends just for fun
[Applause]
yeah I slept with cousin I've cheated on
two of my boyfriends how many boyfriends
have you had three so damn near all it
if Jesus can't save these hoes why are
you trying what is the worst thing X has
done to you nothing honestly my ex
actually been really good to me what's
the first thing you did to ex I cheated
Sensational because he accused me of
cheating so I decided I was actually
going to go do it what the who did you
cheat with a lot of people how many
people maybe four or five Jesus Christ
he never found out I I was sck with it I
was
sck yeah I got away with
that this is crazy I couldn't believe
when she said I [__] cousins yeah
right cousins what is that like in I
mean I know it's not incest but incest
it well no I think incest they have to
do it to each other that's like an
Alabama thing I know it's not but but we
don't know about that over yeah yeah
Alabama they're like known for yeah I
look it don't yeah that's a different
conversation but but I'm like you and
the one girl who thought let me screw
the whole friend
group what does that accomplish guys
where are you finding these friends
these people well and and the thing is
it's like if you're doing that he's
going to be happy he got rid of you yeah
true true I just don't get why you would
brag about it for the whole world cuz
then these are the same women who are
going to complain the single and
childless well and the funny thing is
okay they're like saying oh these guys
you know are so like they'll call men
trash and then publicly say stuff like
this I just I'm I'm struggling to
believe that this is where
yeah well okay I bet you one or two
maybe was stage that does happen on
YouTube but I'm like you just start to
see so many of these stories pop up you
can't really deny them anymore you're
like some something's
real um let's look at the C the comments
in the video let's pull it up women used
to be shamed for this type of Behavior
now it's celebrated what
happened what did happen um I just think
they got rid of consequences I think men
just kept bailing him out yeah yeah have
you seen there's a video I want to react
to it of these guys going on dates with
girls that have like red flags and they
wanted to see if she said every single
red flag okay if he would still date her
cuz she was really attractive okay so I
think I've done a reaction similar to
this it's like an actress yeah and she
like pretends to said yes I'm like what
are you doing they meant to be doing a
part two where the guy does like a red
flag to see how many women will say yes
waiting on it to come out I'm I'm sure
marsupio gamer says keep this in mind
when women complain about not finding a
good man to marry when or when older
women gripe about older men dating
20-year-olds we've seen what you're like
in your 20s ladies you get no sympathy
after you hit that wall at 35 I think
more of this mindset is needed really
because at the end of the day it's like
you said women aren't facing the
consequences if they start facing the
consequences maybe you'll start to see a
change but until then why would they
change when they just get free pass
Melanie says not all women are like this
but this is what Garners the most
attention online all you focus on are
poor qualities in the opposite sex
that's all you'll find we don't give
honorable women the same type of
attention if not more I disagree there
was a woman that went on fresh and fit
she also went on my show but she wore a
mask she was a 22-year-old virgin okay
that had all of these housewife skills
she liked to fish she cooked from
scratch like all of the traditional
stuff she went stupid viral right it's
just I'm sorry I've done Street
interviews and the amount of crazy you
might not get as many like insane
answers like that but you don't get
amazingly honorable answers left and
right and I just think it's the
degradation of society as a whole yeah
Kenny says Freedom consists in not doing
what we like but in having the right to
do what we ought yeah because it used to
come with responsibility yeah you know I
mean there's a reason we had terms like
a shotgun wedding
is that when someone would get pregnant
and then they'd have to get married like
yeah the GU the dad would put a gun to
the guy's head where it comes from yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like basically the
dad has a shotgun now I'm not saying we
do that but the point was people knew
that if you made the wrong choice you
took the respon there was a consequence
that came with it and today we have no
consequences because again men will
still marry these chicks a lot of the
time if they're good-look enough that's
it a true crime is being fat to men
though I truly I truly think men would
take a single mother over a fat chick I
don't no I don't know if if the reality
is she's not losing weight because most
fat people do not lose weight no it's
like I I think and I'd have to you guys
let me know in the comments I think guys
would take a single mom over a fat sh
I'm intrigued to know I'm intrigued to
know so do you have any idea who Sophia
Franklin is speaking of modern women
okay have you heard of call her daddy uh
no like yes and no I think call her
daddy was a is it a podcast it was a
podcast it was really big like 10 years
ago and it was basically two modern
women talking about their sexual
escapades on the internet this woman
basically taught an entire generation of
women to
do sexual favors for a man how
to you catch my yeah you catch my drift
right now two of them one one kind of
got kicked out of the podcast right yeah
one girl they kind of got to do a big
fight the two girls right one is engaged
now and is now worth like 50 million
yeah so one girl I mean obviously is a
Catholic I don't think that's worth it
to sell your soul for money but a lot of
people would argue that was worth it
this other girl in the other hand just
did it for free and now has a small
media career but really nothing really
came of it she's 31 okay and on first
dates which one's this the one with the
money or the one without the money no
money no money she has she demands to
see men's bank accounts on first dates
why because basically if they're not
rich enough she wants to be protected
and provided for and I think yeah I know
I know and I think that's I'm not even
saying that's well okay the bank account
is too far but I don't even think it's
bad to select for a man with resources
but my problem is when you pick
resources over character because in this
industry I have seen people with
Millions come and go yeah like I've seen
people that get rich overnight some
spend it all in one day others can keep
it for 10 20 years and the funny thing
is most rich men have their money in
real estate so the fact that she's
asking for a bank account is ridiculous
in itself no it just mean she's stupid
yeah yeah yeah anyway so here she goes
on um Logan Paul's show and Mike I
forgot his last it's like majernik or
something know um and I wanted to talk
about a dynamic that I see which is men
with a more gynocentric worldview where
they put the women's priorities first
appease women and don't tell them how
ridiculous they sound true and it
doesn't help us because we go through
life never hearing how stupid we sound
never being told we're wrong exactly and
so there's the clip of them on the
podcast okay um not so not only I
watched more of it than we're going to
show but they ALS Al talk about how hard
a woman's life is and this woman got
famous this woman got famous and she
could have gotten Rich too if she worked
out her deal with her friend right she
could be worth 25 million right now or
10 five whatever it is um for a lot more
than most people that's for sure she got
a ton of opportunity for doing what
suck exactly exactly um okay so here
here is the clip let me show you do I
get a second
date
how do I know this isn't
photoshopped yeah I would give that a
second dat do
I it's it's in the top right you gota
like Zoom yeah oh there's no way you can
say yes like that the same way to both
of them his should have got a more
should have got a more resounding you
asked me he should have got a more
resounding yes you asked me well what I
am shocked I am shocked what how little
it is no no no I'm shocked that her
reaction was so oh so similar because
this is no I think maybe because no you
know
what what kind of of can weo it no no no
are these some I'll jump on the couch
for Logan's response no no no no no for
both for both both both of you guys
what's the max are very successful
what's the max you've seen in a bank
account on the first
date I I honestly 30 I maybe pretty
checking okay but this is this is the
thing okay so I wanted to point out
instead of saying you sound ridiculous
which could have helped her right in the
long term that's something that could
help her in because if you don't face
reality reality will hit you in the face
at some point so if you don't accept
this is reality yes and sneo went viral
basically saying you ran through 30 Oney
old chick how do you have the yeah how
do you have the audacity to ask someone
for their bank account on their first
date yeah now that's harsh but it's
helpful and it's true yes and then she
can adapt but the problem is men like
this they know what's true I mean they
they're not stupid they know that's
ridiculous you know even even Logan
Paul's girlfriend I know I think she
kind of convinced him that it was so
maybe he believes whatever she's saying
to him maybe maybe it's true I don't
know but
even he said that he liked her because
she made him
wait meaning he likes a certain type of
chick now in the red pill space they
kind of know that typically that's not
that means she's sleeping with someone
else or you're just not that guy to her
right in the red pill but that's not
common in mainstream nice so um my point
is they could have said something that
helped her but instead they started
qualifying themselves Fu her yeah they
said are we good enough for you when
really it's like it's putting her
automatically up here ex which is
gynocentric thinking instead of thinking
what do you do to qualify for me I I'm
the one who's worked hard for all of
this time to to make this amount of
money but yet they're still bowing down
to her when it should be okay if you've
worked as hard to have a certain amount
of numbers in your bank account then you
should be the one qualifying female and
the thing is Mike was tweeting at me cuz
I tweeted
I
tweeted women with tattoos are not
attractive right now as a woman you have
some tattoos now does that mean I think
every chick that gets a tattoo is ugly
no but by and large it's not what men
select for when you look at and when you
look at things that are more unfiltered
so like what an example of sex dolls
97% are tattooist yeah yeah yeah yeah
now this information is helpful because
you know you could have just continued
and gotten a
sleeve I mean I wouldn't but yeah no not
not you but like you you see but it's
like women we have no idea what men want
and so then they'll always he'll s and
be like of course there's women that are
attractive with tattoos I'm like
obviously obviously there's exceptions
to every rule there's exceptions to
every rule but the point is less is
better more is worse men aren't really
checking for women with with with
sleeves chest T that's not their thing
typically and you look at their
girlfriends none of them have visible
tattoos are super big they might have a
small thing whatever but you you see
what I'm saying and the problem is this
mindset allows us to live in delusion
and we'll hate on channels like myin
sneo where maybe they're a bit harsh
their delivery might be harsh but what
they're saying is helpful and true and
honest same with Kevin Samuels like
there's women that danced on his grade
or like that were dancing and
celebrating when he died yeah sorry not
his actual grave but they were on social
media dancing celebrating that he died
yeah and the the saddest part is those
men actually care for women more more
because they care more about looking
good than saying what is
true what
SS okay let's look at the comment
section and I don't even think they're
bad people but it's like I don't
sometimes I just think we've been
programmed and especially men have been
programmed from such a young age to
always think about what the women want
that they don't even think about what is
true because it's true that we live in a
gynocentric society everything is
catering to women absolutely everything
um and it's the point that you always
make of you know when you mess up the
order of the world things start to go
wrong and we start to see evil and what
you just told me you know there's women
on the internet dancing over the fact
that someone is dead that's horrific
yeah um wgard so she sees the bank
account on the first date yeah well what
it's like do you give sex probably I
can't imagine um co-star they just
tricked her into showing her gold digger
status she's a six out of 10 why does
she think she can be a gold digger I
don't think that's the issue here um I
don't think the issue obviously looks
are obviously a massive factor for guys
I think the part that we should be
highlighting is if she had done or had
any characteristics that would qualify
her for these men you know like you say
selecting for resources is a feminine
tra however she's over 30 her fertility
is going to be a lot lower she also is
in this position of being able to talk
to these men because she made a career
out of tainting young girls and teaching
young girls how to be
[__] she absolutely does not qualify
to be vetting these men and the saddest
part I actually I want to do a sit down
with the girls from caller Daddy it's
actually one of my like kind of dream
collabs because I honestly want to ask
them you influenced an entire generation
of
I it was in the US you don't even
understand it was such a popular show it
was so like they were like the hot
YouTube channel all of the young people
were watching them and it's like how
does it feel to have influenced a
generation of women yeah negatively I I
would argue negatively maybe they think
you know and I've heard um Alex Cooper
talk about her which is the rich one um
I've that's who I that's who I know of
you yeah that I've heard heard her talk
about like how you know she's so happy
that these women are empowered and
confident and I I genuinely think in her
head she believes she's doing good for
the world but the problem is we have
this media we have all this stuff that's
just lying to us constantly yeah and it
worked out for her but I mean Alex
probably was an eight out of 10 in her
prime we say it worked out for her how
old is she um she's like late 20s she's
engaged it actually I mean on paper
let's see 20 years St the line
yeah I know I know but I I know yeah I
know because typically they're too
damaged so you can kind of see I'm
actually going to do a show on the I
think the guilt will creep up on them
because there's overwhelming evidence to
suggest that this kind of behavior is
not good for women um and I think you
know will for ignorance just means that
they kind of they convince themselves
that they believe it and that they think
they're doing good but I think over time
especially if they have daughters for
themselves I think I think like you say
you can BL you can blur the lines of
reality but reality will snap back and
hit you in the face and I think it will
snap back and hit them in the face in 20
years down the line if it's not guilt it
will be some kind of marriage failure or
that's what I was going to say yeah I'm
actually cuz she like on paper though
she's an eight out of 10 she's engaged
now and she's worth 50 million on paper
this is amazing for her but the problem
is I think she's going to be too damaged
and eventually she's going to divorce
yeah like that that's my prediction if I
had to guess and and so if I had to
interview them honestly i w really
wanted to ask the question if if they
genuinely think they had a positive
impact on the world yeah because I think
they I really think they believe this
but you know we need that interview make
it happen I know I know I want oh I want
to do a show on pretty privilege if it's
actually a privilege because I I started
tweeting about the who are the prettiest
women of the 80s and 90s and I just
wanted to test if they were married
still and the majority were not so was
pry priv I see what say yeah is it a
blessing or a curse because when you
think about it it's like if a girl is a
four out of 10 she has to really work to
be a good person yeah her character and
Thomas soel talked about this he says
who's to say that the people with beauty
are blessed because they eventually lose
it and who's like he was you think about
like School the prettiest girls were
always the ones like getting up to
nonsense and they get lazy a lot of
times cuz life is just handed to them
yeah so a lot of times what'll happen is
they get fat later because they don't
have the discipline to stay like they've
never worked hard at anything in their
life or like you know they're they're
not they didn't have to be you know the
four out of 10 has to work to get in a
relationship it depends on what you're
defining as privileged doesn't it
because if you're defining as privilege
you know these handouts and like the
instant gratification then absolutely
Prett privilege is a thing but it's it's
this you know the shift in in culture
when you look at the fact that we're
gynocentric now it's like okay we we can
say pretty privileges a thing because in
our society we've put so much value in
things that are like money selfish
things instant gratification but it's
like we talk about what's actually going
to fulfill the soul and make you feel
good things like a family great
relationships having a good character
yeah
exactly being pretty actually when you
look at the patterns in society probably
doesn't lead to that yeah well because I
was thinking of the girls that they
mentioned and it was one was Jennifer
Aniston who I actually I wouldn't have
even put her up there like to be honest
I wouldn't put her I would have put her
as a solid seven yeah in her prime I
mean she's beautiful she's aged super
well they put Angelina Jolie yeah also
folks yeah yeah also do like all of
these women um what was the other one
that was married to the pastor I always
forget her name but Megan good um
another one that's now divorced Sierra I
guess we'll see oh I think one uh munis
yeah she's married they're still married
aren't they yeah there's an exception
there yeah oh she's up there too yeah
but you know the question is is by and
large is pretty a privilege I I'm going
to do a show on this one day it's kind
of a good question like is it is it a
privilege you know even Alex Cooper now
she's worth $50 million that's
generational wealth that's
amazing but odds are she's GNA die alone
if I had to guess if I had to get women
that have been in her position in the
past don't typically lead la
happy marriages typically that's really
interesting and the thing is half the
time these women they get this money and
they don't know what to do with it and
so if you are new to investing and you
have savings you need to protect right
now with the Middle East War the Ukraine
war and maybe even Taiwan you need a new
playbook that is safe allocate some gold
now and avoid frenzied Panic of the
unprepared when fear Reigns gold
protects the wise Noble gold Investments
offers a free 5 ounce America the
beautiful coin with new IRAs this month
Shield your savings with Noble gold
Investments Ira go to noblegold
investments.com that's noblegold
investments.com that is the only gold
company that I trust so the next thing I
wanted to talk about
was I think there's an anti-white
campaign going on really yeah I know so
you can never say you have white pride
and especially no no no I know I know I
know but you could say I have black
pride that's fine but if you say I have
white pride then suddenly it's a problem
this was super prevalent when I was in
college I when I was in college you're a
couple years younger so maybe high
school that was when the BLM movement
was going full force um a couple years
after college and it was so crazy the
amount of women that would say things
like I hate straight white men we got
literally taught this in my media a
level our teacher who was a uh Canadian
white lady in her 30s single obviously
um she uh yeah we literally got taught
in our media classes that middle-aged
white men are evil and that they are
like the source of all the world's
problems and every analysis that we
would do of a piece of media it would
always come down to and who's this owned
by and everyone would sort of
collectively go a middle-aged white man
and I just started yeah and I used I
used to get really peed off with it and
I used to sort of you know stand up for
middle-aged white men and and go like
you can acknowledge patterns in certain
industries but one why is that pattern
there you know could it be that
middle-aged white men perhaps have more
time on their hands so that's why
they're in those positions but even
still if it is something else does that
then mean that all middle-aged white men
are these evil oppressors I was like my
dad's a middleaged white man he doesn't
have the same amount of money as Rupert
Murdoch well and the other thing they
don't talk about is maybe there's things
about they always act like white people
can't have culture and I'm like there
are absolutely things that are white
culture I'll give you an example so I
grew up with German nannies right so
maybe it's German culture technically
but we had Traditions that were
literally from Germany and I'm my mom's
side is German right and it was actually
kind of cool we would have like these
cones on the first day of school they
would fill it would be like a
celebration your first day of school
it's like a German thing okay and even
just certain like traditions that that
were German I grew up with and they act
like we we can have any type of culture
yeah and I think it's them trying to
eradicate it I don't know why I don't
know why there's this huge well racism
has just kind of flipped hasn't it I
mean I see this whole thing where it's
like you know the whole idea of white
privilege came into play um and it's
like now I I see these people and and
the way they talk about white people
it's essentially like it's the whole
thing's just on a U-turn like we were
supposed to come to some point of
equilibrium where we could all
acknowledge you know the definition of
racism which you know prejudice against
someone because of the color of their
skin whereas we seem to have gone past
the middle point and just completely
gone in the opposite direction where now
it's like oh racism is okay as long as
it's against white people yeah well and
did you see my story the other day oh
yeah he who will not be named he who
will not be named will not be named I
didn't realize he was um a racist yeah
he literally said you can't be racist
against white people which is absolutely
ridiculous it's absolutely ridiculous
I'm I'm thinking if you see
color that that probably indicates that
you've got a problem there if you if you
you know think that a per a person's
color of their skin and where they come
from on planet Earth somehow makes any
difference in in their ability to be a
human being and that we all have the
same inate
value you've got some racial isues going
on there if you if you think that like
if you if you're a black person and you
see a white person and you automatically
make all of these assumptions on them
because of the color of their skin that
is racist in the same way if you are a
white person and you see a black person
you make all of these assumptions on who
they are as a human being because of the
color of their skin you are a racist
well and I remember when I was younger I
actually I felt guilty when I was a kid
for like being because they would always
be like oh rich white people and I'm
like well that's where yeah you know
what I mean like I'm like and but you
know when you realize you're like you
realize if you live in the west you're
richer than like 80% of yeah yeah but so
there is this video going viral that
shows the impact of this on the media
and the culture let's pull it up I am
proud to be
like 3 2
1 just be in the middle yeah can there
be a
middle all right got to pick a side
I don't know what
to don't hate me guys I don't I almost
went there too it's like I think like
guiltily like I'm like happy that I'm
not oppressed but I'm not proud of like
things people have done in the past when
I when I think of being proud of
something I think of something I worked
for or that um I yeah I had to get I I
had to do nothing to be white absolutely
nothing and nothing was taken from me
because I was white it's like saying I'm
a proud white person is a completely
different saying than saying I'm a proud
black person because when you hear I'm a
proud black person I think empowerment I
think strength I think courage I think
you know all these amazing things that
the black community has done and
accomplished throughout the years but
then when you say I am a strong or I'm a
proud white person already there's so
much like hate involved in that thing
about that is like like how you said
someone who says I'm proud of be black
that's empowerment why aren't I allowed
to be proud to be white what makes it
wrong you haven't been oppressed yeah
what are you proud of just your skin
color because yes that is wrong so
you're saying I can't be proud to be
white because I don't have a culture no
I that's not what I'm saying I that I
when white people say they're proud to
be white a lot of times at least in my
opinion they're just they're talking
about their skin color that they're not
a different race I think that's wrong
yeah but um as like we were talking
about as as a proud black person they've
been oppressed that a lot of their
culture was stolen from them and a lot
of reasons that I don't like proud to be
white is because it has the the Nazis
used it the the the KKK used it I don't
want to be associated with any of those
things so I'm just G to completely stay
away from that sure I'm not proud of
like what my culture's done but at the
same time like I would not want to be
anything else if I had to choose another
race I don't know what I would be I'm
okay with where I am even though I'm
getting back backlash about being
white this is propaganda of identity
politics and it's PE whoever is the
producer for this show you are inciting
racism right now because I actually
agreed with that man when he started
with the fact of like what it means to
be proud why the hell are we asking
people are you a proud white person are
you a proud black person what the hell
does the color of your skin have to do
with whether you are a proud person why
do we divide people into these groups
still to this day how many years has it
been since segregation and still to this
day it is oh that's a black guy that's a
white guy that's a Hispanic guy no it's
just a guy and if you live in this world
of identity politics you are the people
who are inciting racism because you are
creating the segregation of people based
on the color of their skin that is what
was meant to have been abolished and
here we are we're inciting it again
we're fueling again I don't know how
people can't see this this is this is
this is a racist video well and it's
interesting too because they say I'm not
proud of what my culture has done you
know the word like SLO because I'm sure
it's slavery right but the word slave
comes from Slavic Irish was the number
one form of slaves in the United States
before 1800 or 7 I don't remember which
year but it's like it like I we can play
the whole game of who's been more
oppressed who's who's had more slaves
white people or black people people the
truth is that argument can go on for
Millennia till the end of time we can
all do the point scoring men were like
we can all do it at the end of the day
we all human beings and if you have to
identify yourself based on something
like what you look like or anything like
that instead of your character
unfortunately that's what's part of the
problem and I'll tell you one thing you
know ever since I was a kid I loved
being a redhead M that's like one thing
ever since like I was young my mom just
always told me that she she always
wanted kids with red hair and she was so
happy we had red hair and so ever since
I was a kid I just thought it was
amazing I was like nobody else has red
hair right I get to have red hair and
this is all like I know they would have
the ginger like every ginger doesn't
hair being a ginger is brutal I you know
and I honestly think it might have been
I definitely had jokes made but I just
didn't care because I loved being a
ginger like I just loved it I I just
thought it was awesome I thought it was
awesome being tall and I think you can
kind of celebrate having something
unique about you but it it would be like
if you celebrate it too hard then you're
you're being too proud to be white you
know and you can't celebrate things that
are associated with being white yeah I
just think it's I just think the only
way out of this whole you know space of
of racism Morgan Freeman says it you
know the only way to get out of it is to
stop talking about it I think you know
the idea that you can have something
different you know yeah you can have
things that different about the way you
look you can also have things that are
different about your character and I
think that's where the issue lies is the
fact that we don't we don't celebrate
things that are good in character it's
always about it's always about how you
look it
kind outside it kind of goes back to the
superficiality because again they're not
talking about your character it's about
something that's looks wise and it's the
same thing with like they're not talking
about your charity how how much have you
done to help people mhm um and so the
comment says they managed to convinc an
entire population that they're somehow
guilty and should be ashamed of the
color of their skin racism against white
people is the only kind of
discrimination that's allowed fact the
left demands that white people carry
white guilt because it makes them easier
to manipulate yeah well it's that whole
argument of what you said you know is it
that racism is just essentially flipped
and they're trying to eradicate white
people perhaps I just think this whole
thing is absolutely ridiculous there is
no reason to feel guilt when you did
nothing wrong and are being used used by
an agenda there's no reason to feel
guilt when you did nothing wrong and are
being used by an agenda by the radical
left yeah I'm like what did I do there
also no reason to be proud of the color
of your skin black or white like why is
that you're something you're proud of
I'm proud because I have a certain type
of pigment in my skin what I don't okay
I disagree with you a little bit I I
disagree with you a little bit I think
there's some like I don't know I kind of
look like my dad and I kind of am proud
of the fact cuz you know I'm so close
with my like I think there's some maybe
maybe Pride you know because pride is
the sin maybe Pride isn't the best way
to put it but I think you can have some
sort of level of appreciation
appreciation is different to Proud to
the features that I don't know that you
get from your family you know I think
you can appreciate patterns because they
perhaps you associate certain
characteristics through those patterns I
mean your dad is an entrepreneur he's
successful man he's a father to 10
children he's done things that you
appreciate and you see as something good
so you know there's a difference between
going I I like the fact that I look like
my dad because when I think of my dad it
incites all of these positive emotions
in me whereas you know just going on
social media and I I'm a I'm a proud
this I'm a proud that oh yeah yeah when
you leave because you're leading with it
that's what you're leading with yeah
that's the problem I almost think it
makes it sad all the surgery people are
getting in a way because it's like you
almost lose what makes you look like you
oh yeah like plastic surgery yeah cuz
all the girls kind of look the same
the exact the duck lips the that does
move it's like you kind of used to look
like your parents yeah you the disgust
to me is liberal seeing everything
through the lens of race be proud of who
you are regardless of your skin color I
don't understand how anyone can be
negative towards a skin color that God
gave them yeah the only thing I disagree
with there is be proud of who you are
regardless of your skin color no no no
no no there are a lot of people out
there who should not be proud of who
they are and what they've done be be
proud of who you are if you've done
enough to to the other people admire
what you've done but yeah no I
completely agree how could how it's just
so ridiculous the whole race argument
and it's so you know the leftist they
say oh we're we're equality we're
inclusion but it's like you're literally
putting people into groups based on
their skin color
what speaking of um I
guess traits that people are looking to
pass on I saw the weirdest Twitter post
okay I don't think I've been this
Bamboozled and just like confused in a
long time let's pull it up so there's a
woman that tweeted hello Twitter peeps
my friend Elizabeth is looking for an
unvaccinated sperm donor her
requirements are blue-eyed white 511 or
taller STD free no Jewish or African
ancestry follows a healthy meat focused
diet must be a natural insemination she
will not do IVF DM
me
um her details are German and Swedish
ancestry a two body count been celibate
the last 2.5 years 23 years old
unvaccinated meat focused diet
supplements D3 and K2 will have support
of grandmother and younger brother
insemination must be natural in person
in eastern USA she was not looking for a
husband or boyfriend she will remain
celibate after this what the
[__] um your schedule must be free to
accommodate her ovulation schedule she
will give you as much notice as possible
she has decided not to go up she has
decided not to go through with the
upfront fee so don't worry about that
she's asking that you remain in touch
for future reinsemination as she is
looking to have three children over the
next 5 years as you can see she is
incredibly beautiful pure-blooded
European intelligent and has a
childbearing body your Offspring will be
raised extremely well please DM me your
application I will be in touch for
further details if she deems you
qualified
I know I saw I I was like this cannot be
real Tristan Tate comments
disgusting I know I know that it's so
funny you're reaction that was mine I'm
like this can't this has got to be fake
this has got your Offspring will be
raised very well yeah we know how these
stories with single moms go why would
you pick that why would you
like why on Earth would you choose to be
a single mother literally and I think it
shows something about society and their
lack of appreciation for fathers you
need a strong masculine figure in the
kid's life and she is picking this I
actually am quite speechless for me it's
it's really quite scary because what we
are seeing is a a public admittance to
Eugenics I mean listen to the wording p
blooded yeah you know she's got all of
these things she's this is completely
evil and unnatural completely you like
Tristan says disgusting disgusting
absolutely disgusting dehumanizing of
you to suggest that a man should be
willing and able to casually agree to
this kids need their fathers and fathers
need their
children absolutely absolutely and I
completely agree you know that's a
that's a big issue here I'm just I'm
more concerned about the the humanity if
issue of this this is this is this is
this is evil this is really evil I don't
think she's
23 I just I'm not buying does she look
23 to you that was she looks like she
needs to be behind bars this is really
bad those things that she's saying is
like that's what led us into World War
II that's you know the I know we can't
say his name on YouTube but the guy who
was the leader of Germany this is that
same ideology yeah and she's publicly
admitt God I I don't know if we're going
to see the eugenic stuff per se as much
but I think we're going to see more of
the sperm donor where women just like
are not going to want to pay the cost
yeah where so they they just essentially
just want kids but they don't want their
kids to have a dad well they don't think
they can get the type of guy that they
would want to keep you know what I mean
so I I think it's them picking I want
people not understand like how DNA works
I don't know these people are crazy I I
just saw this I was like you think oh
right so if the guy is not around purely
based on environmental factors I'm going
to be able to mold this child into what
I want do do you not realize that you
know literally everything is in our DNA
just get a sperm donor yeah just amazing
that I'm sure this is going to work out
well for her um okay actually shocked
me I seriously I saw this and I was like
what on Earth
because I'm like okay let me get this
straight your okay let me get this
straight lady your idea of kids that are
going to be raised well is putting out
an application on on
Twitter Twitter okay all right all right
um please no one give this woman yeah
guys there someone's gonna do it
someone's gonna come on someone's gonna
do it um so I wanted to talk about you
know I think the theme is women being
just so out of pocket and I started
thinking about how we really got to this
point like how do we get so delusional
and crazy and I thought about a show
that actually was super popular when I
was in high school okay do you have you
heard of Gray's Anatomy yes okay I'm
going to show you a clip from it okay
and I want to see what you notice pull
it up love you
April I always
have I love everything about you even
even the things I don't
like I
love and I want you with
me I love you and I think that you love
me
too once upon a
time and you April and Matthew's closest
friends and family are here today to
Bear witness to their Union will you
promise to love and support their
marriage in all the days to come if so
please respond we
will
now I I have known the two of you for
quite some
time I'm sorry stand up I'm happy to be
here today to be able to do this for
[Music]
you I don't know what to do I'm always
in the living
[Music]
what did you notice from this
clip why didn't her husband who she's
actually getting married to punch him in
the
face first of all
okay why was everyone acting like this
was this really beautiful amazing moment
that like two lovers have it's the whole
like Romeo and Juliet [__] like two
lovers have just they've just realized
their love for each other how's that
going to work out long term how how are
you guys then going to get married you
know and what you're not you're not
going to remember this whole thing where
like she was about to get married and
then I mean judging by the the tone of
that scene I imagine I'm not seeing
Gray's Anatomy but I imagine she goes
yes I love you too and they have this
moment where they realize their love for
each other
like why why why I just can't understand
why I do I do know they date for a
couple years in the show my sister's
watched it so like sometimes I would
watch a couple episodes but I never was
that into it I noticed something else
okay one why is the ex-boyfriend at the
wedding right cuz they dated before Oh
my gosh yeah yeah yeah um two what would
you rate her one to
10 five four I actually I was going to
give her a six okay six maybe five six
that's what I would say I she look like
she had some wet done okay maybe five
whatever whatever okay let's just say
she's a five normal looking chick why
how does she get now she has two eights
or higher fighting over her I was like
this is the most unrealistic thing I
have ever seen in my life you're telling
me this average chick has two men the
the one guy in the in the um the one guy
I know the one guy is a doctor I don't
remember what the other guy does the one
guy that like got up okay you're telling
me Jackson Avery okay Jesse
Williams one of like very attractive
dude second very attractive dude are
fighting over a six a five in what world
in what world I'm like it's no wonder
we're so delusional because you have all
of these shows showing average women
getting these amazing results I mean
also why why did everyone just passively
sit there and let this unfold like let's
believe if this was happening in real
life if I was about to get married right
first of all my ex wouldn't even be
there but let's say your ex is there
right yeah for whatever messed up
deluded reason he stands up SP my family
are going what the hell get out of here
what are you doing you're embarrassing
get out what is going on but no
everyone's just like oh look at this
beautiful moment where they realize
their love what it goes back to and I
think it shows something about the
culture right and it goes back to the
theme of The One That Got Away yeah and
yeah it's a very common theme that we
see in the media and the culture we had
a song that I mean you know the Katy
Perry Perry The One That Got Away the
one that wrecked my heart I should have
never let him go I should have begged
him to stay he was the one that got away
and so I think that you really have a
generation of women there's a reason
that that show was so popular the theme
of the main character which is Meredith
also it's the one that got away she in
the beginning hooks up with this doctor
right that she's whatever then he goes
back she finds out he's still
technically married and then the whole
thing is like this love triangle same
with you know Olivia Pope have you ever
SE it's this other other show this girl
named Olivia Pope she's the side chick
to the president and it's always he was
the one that got away it's like we see
all these seeds planted within our
culture and then we wonder why we're
growing [__] crops exactly yeah because
again really in a truly an honest thing
it would be the women fighting over him
you are not going to have two grown men
that are doctors in their mid-30s like
okay maybe at 22 some guys are naive I
thought you brought me on here for a bit
of fun you know I thought it's going to
be fun I'm going to have to go away and
sit in a dark room because you're just
destroying my faith in humanity right
sorry that's what I do best anyways so
the comments say wrong timing to me very
selfish on his end what about the others
correct but why would you wait for her
wedding day yeah I'm like how long was
the average engagement so funny the
average dating period before getting
engaged is three years the average
engagement is one year so I'm like
you've had like four years also I think
that shows you that a woman probably
wrote this because chances of a man
doing that very low chances of a woman
doing that very high yeah exactly so it
should have been flipped it would have
been more likelihood is it would have
been a woman who stood up and said you
know but this is what they're trying to
do they're trying to flip the order of
things and tell you that this is what
could happen no absolutely not yeah no
guy no guy is going to do that
especially with like a bigger like he
looks tall and good shap also I'm more
looking at it from the perspective of
the fact that women are more selfish so
women are the ones less likely to
consider the fact oh this is their
wedding day you know maybe I shouldn't
do that for their sake if I love them
then I'm not going to embarrass them on
their wedding day I think a woman is
more likely to go ah [__] all of that
this is how I feel let tell about
it so once you start to notice
gynocentrism which again disrupts the
natural order of the world women amazing
women a pedestal yeah women on a
pedestal you start to notice who still
has gynocentric thinking and who doesn't
and this isn't like ever an attack on
anybody I I mean at some point I've said
gynocentric things you don't notice it
until you see it right and I saw this
video of sneo and myin debating whether
we need women to survive let's P it up
yo my is so [__] heterosexual he's
like we don't need women to survive I'm
like well you know life is better he's
like we don't need them we don't true
what's the point of even arguing for
that like what's the point of living if
there's no women there's no point I'm
saying we don't need them to survive
it's the point but there's no point in
living so you're not going to want to
survive but you can survive without them
why would you survive if there were no
women why would you even do it there's
other ways to derive pleasure where you
don't need
females yeah women are a luxury bro
what okay so I wanted to give a couple
different notes that I noticed he said
there's no I think he said something
along the lines of there's no point to
life if there's no women along the lines
yeah I would disagree because there have
been very many influential men in
history that have had no women by this
logic
Jesus there was no point to
Jesus yeah um Sir Isaac Newton is
another one there's actually great men
in history really there have been great
men in history that have died virgins um
because they believed that women were a
distraction and they were so focused on
their purpose no I think myON is is
speaking the most facts here but it's
just you know it's facts and it's true
but only up until the end of your life
yeah that's the that other than that
like you know when you it depends what
you mean by survive you know survive
until the day you die absolutely there's
other ways to get pleasure than from the
and you know sn's whole thing is very
gentric in his thinking but um you know
I the the flip argument is like okay but
if you want your species to continue of
of course you need women for that yeah
other than that I think the premise of
the argument the point that you know men
these days seem to have been put in a
position because of the gentric culture
where they are told women are this prize
women are basically the ultimate goal to
life um it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous yeah and even you don't even
have a guarantee that your Offspring
Will Survive for example George
Washington now people say that he had
kids out of wedlock so we don't know
this for sure okay but on paper he had
no children okay he still influenced
history M he had a wife and it's like by
this logic did he not have a life worth
living because he didn't have kids
because a lot of times it's insinuated
that then the children if it's not the
women then it's the children you have to
do it for the children but I'm like no
there and I don't think men have this
natur reproduces I don't think men have
this naturally where they put women on a
pedestal like when boys are young
they're still exploring they think women
have cooe like this isn't natural it's
like the world has women hold them back
when they're young it's more like oh you
know I have to slow down because of the
girls whereas if you let men just boys
if you let boys just sort of go and
explore they're very like they will
spearhead the whole thing and so they
say like what is the point of living
well I mean I mean I think if women
weren't around and we obviously we need
women families are amazing and whatever
but my point is the man's purpose has to
come first yeah and if a woman doesn't
come along I don't think it's like a
life that's not worth living no
absolutely not they would have explored
like the bottom of the ocean if there
was no wi that's the thing I'm like guys
would find something to do they would
like they would build something you
wouldn't have any roombas or decorations
it would just be like men exploring
they' be doing [__] yeah um thinking
like isn't worth living without women is
gynocentric thinking many men that were
very influential in history died virgins
fact yeah South Side rer sneo is right
that is not gynocentric thinking it is
human thinking no sneo is not right sneo
is actually limiting himself to all the
potential that he could have as a human
being because he's putting his ultimate
driv in life down to you know the
affection and from women but it's like
there's so much more to life than that
you know it's nice yeah love can be a
beautiful thing but I mean come on it's
sneo he's probably not referring to love
here there's so much there's so much
more um Savage League says that's an
interesting perspective it's true that
many influential people throughout
history have achieved greater things
without the presence of a romantic
partner and I would say typically and I
just hate to women are always we are
always going to come with emotional bag
correct so even the pure virgin woman is
still going to want to tell you about
her day correct she's still going to
want to talk to you like that's part of
being in a relationship and I think
typically a man that really outsources
everything that just gets a cook cleaner
is going to be able to accomplish more
than typically he's less tied down to
other sacrifices isn't he and I'm not
saying life isn't all about you I think
there's absolutely amazing things about
sacrificing your life for a family but I
I think that we just say women are so
special and amazing and awesome and men
would not create and accomplish without
women I don't
because I think that I think that their
accomplishments and drive to do things
comes from God and I think the natural
order of the world goes God men women
children and when and when you say that
life wouldn't be worth living without
women it's almost putting women at the
equivalent of God well God gave adam Eve
as a helper didn't he he didn't give her
he didn't create Eve first and then
create Adam and say you must do ever
think you can in life to impress this
woman exactly if you're going to look at
it from a religious persp perspective
but even if you look at it from a
non-religious perspective you know the
the men who've achieved things in life
if we could look at all of the great
inventions and the great Innovations of
our species and we could see that all of
it was done out of the lust for a woman
then you know I would have to agree with
sneo point but the truth is like you say
that's not the case and actually if if
we look at the men who have done
probably the most influential things um
they've done it when they're in a
position that they're not I hate to use
it but for lack of a better term tied
down by a woman and a family again this
is not to dispute the fact that there is
great service and there is great
admiration for people who do give and
sacrifice for a family but let's not
ignore the fact that it is a sacrifice
you're having to give something up I
can't remember who did this but I know
there was a guy who literally hid from
his wife when he wanted to invent things
I can't and that's why I'm like guys you
know we're kind of a distraction and I'm
not saying sometimes the distraction
makes your life better but it's still a
distraction and I really think that
men's purpose comes from God and that
even if Eve never went into the garden
Adam still would create and explore and
I just think that that is like God's
gift and something he gave men and it's
almost like when they're attributing it
and saying life isn't living without
women you're almost attributing that
thing that God gave you to women and
I've noticed this that when they
describe motherhood you almost describe
it in a way that you would describe God
and again it goes back to the woman is
like becomes the god of the family gism
yeah that's really interesting okay so
last episode Ryan def defle 7652 says
imagine the flip side where a man is
loyal and faithful and providing a
lifestyle to his wife for years and one
day she randomly files for a divorce
they would be livid what what what's
what's the context here okay so last
episode I covered a story of a woman
that was with a man for eight years he
was with a Prof um he was a professional
hockey player okay he gets a contract in
Russia and ghosts her obviously because
he met a Russian women I mean I I think
that like the story writes itself good
luck I would just you got to break up if
your guys going to Russia I mean good
luck competing with those women were
raised to be wives a beautiful imagine
that's that's like that's like sending
okay imagine that's like playing a
one-on-one game against LeBron James you
might as well just not play you might as
well just say you know
what if this guy if this guy has a
chance with these chicks yeah good luck
um and so he's saying imagine the flip
side where a man is loyal and faithful
and providing a lifestyle to his wife
for years and one day she randomly files
her a divorce because it's ironic isn't
it because that's what we see all the
time that's what we see all the time but
her story went stupid viral because it
was so unheard of hear of this all the
time for a man to do that it's so
unheard of for a man to do that to a
woman that it goes and demonized even
though women do it to men
just like she's empowered she's she's
finding what she deserves oh bollock oh
my go I saw a tweet that or I tweeted
this the other day I can't believe how
many women have been on the show and
have told me that they divorced broke up
their family because they out grew their
husband oh I know I'm like
horrific like did you there's no respect
there for I'm like did you did you get a
growth
spur do you know what I mean like did
you get a midline
I don't know but chances are you've been
here before there's chaos in the market
oil and stocks and just when you thought
it was safe and interest rates were
Rising new threats came out of nowhere
tensions are boiling from Asia to Europe
and adaptation is key to safeguarding
your wealth you may not have considered
gold before it's not speculation but
insurance right now we need some
insurance Noble gold Investments has
been protecting investors from disaster
for years with precious m medals so if
you're worried it might be time to take
a fresh look at gold and silver golden
gold is a proven Safe Haven shield for
your portfolio and a volatility balance
against uncertainty if it helps Noble
gold Investments is offering a free 5
ounce America the Beautiful coin with
its new IRAs this month if you open your
Noble gold Investments Ira or 401K
rollover you can claim your coin today
remember crisis Brews your portfolios
might waver but gold insulates secure
yourself against threat go to noblegold
investments.com that is noblegold
investments.com the only gold company I
trust thank you for coming on today
Christine thank you so much for having
me back we will see you next week yeah
yeah every Wednesday I'll be coming and
joining you for the treachery debauchery
and you know just generally destroying
my faith in humanity so thanks for that
you're welcome like the video on your
way out guys subscribe to the channel
and get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt today the link is in the
description we'll talk to you next time